[Musique]
et
l'excellent livre de jean-françois
remonter oui convaincu par ailleurs et
simone debout faut tout faire soi-même
ici les douze caméras réalisé deux
touristes un très bon réalisateur de
radio et qui a consacré ce livre voit ce
qu'on appelle les années radio qui pour
moi ne sont pas terminées mais je dirais
même qu'elle commençait années radio et
mais comme tout le monde si vous êtes
directeur des programmes c'est pas parce
que je suis directeur de france inter
que les années radio commence je crois
que jamais la radio ne sait si bien
porté alors que m'a choqué il nous
faisait savoir que dans ce qu'on appelle
le paf
tout n'est pas toujours facile toutes
les émissions qui est notre vie au
niveau radio et la paille 36 mais elles
ont duré
la première sera enfin verrez c'est
laisser les 50 premières années qui sont
très durs à larrazet après la première
boucle de trois siècles de radio mais
c'était le magazine de pierre bouteiller
j'ai pas trouvé de nom alors maintenant
la première première c'est pas parce
qu'elle repart sans prescription les
petites fiches c'est parce que vous
devez le sable est ce que moi mais moi
oui je sortais les goûts
et puis vous avez été foutu à la porte
parce que vous auriez un tempérament un
petit peu comme ça selon pas du tout
cela très pâle et pour ça marche c'était
après mai 68 ouais c'était foutu à la
porte d'europe comme neuf je te crois
une victime on était plusieurs on était
une charrette de journalistes que tu es
un peu impertinent la pertinence qui est
maintenant maquette un mot d'ordre de un
mot d ordre une question mais en fait
vous savez mes 68 y en a il aura fallu
près de plus de 20 ans 22 ans pour
comprendre moi j'ai eu la malchance de
comprendre trop vite
donc j'étais foutu à la porte d'europe
joie d'être parmi vous et les attaques
et france inter
j'ai pas inquiet france inter avec attac
est absolument si roland dhordain qui
était un très très grand directeur de
radio je voulais profiter de l'occasion
pour le dire très grand directeur de
radio hollandaise mais c'est normal faut
lui rendre hommage comme on lui rend
hommage dans ce livre et qui est venu me
chercher et qui je me rappelle très bien
m'a dit à écouter votre émission
d'emmerdés sur europe venait là faire
chez moi je trouve ça plutôt sympa tina
oui je vais quand même au chômage tout
le temps sans mère déchets sans que sur
les uns des autres
oui je sais vous allez me dire ça va
emmerder de savoir qu'une émission qu'il
trouvait bonne ah bon j'ai constructeurs
alors je suis bien
donc j'étais un chômage la misère gens
là et où il est venu me
ne recueillir et j'ai commencé à france
inter allez nous faire pleurer
kenneth tories et la vie c'est comme ça
que je suis mais arrêtez moi si je suis
trop long post mais non mais je voudrais
qu'on retourne un petit peu sur toutes
ces radios qui nous entoure et moi
continue un petit peu la description sig
a pas de poste à galène déjà censé alors
si on a la balle et que l'exposition qui
a ici en quelque sorte un peu d'histoire
du son c'est ce que j'ai essayé de faire
parce que en fin de compte on aurait pu
ramener des milliers de radios des
milliers d'objets et si on a un petit
peu toutes les périodes qui sont
restitués à travers des design surtout
cheval et les formes sont intéressants
durée pour les gens qui regardent dans
la télévision
et puis on va voir donc ça démarre un
petit peu avec le bois ensuite ont tenté
des meubles départ carrément et toute la
famille shaw réclusion regarder la radio
ont regardé la radio toute la famille
était installée puis regardez la radio
c'est une des raisons d'ailleurs pour
lesquels ils emballent länder qui laisse
à bien des gens écoutent la télévision
tous les designers qui les fabriquait
ont fait autant d'efforts en france avec
des centaines de fabricants de radio ça
il faut le savoir également ce qui fait
qu'il ait une multitude de formes une
multitude d'objets ensuite on va passer
à la bakélite après le bois qui était
avant guerre aux états unis qui est venu
après bien en europe et bon cccc forment
un petit peu spectaculaires comme cette
crossley qui fait un peu la calandre de
voitures ou 7 zénith la galerie qui est
un petit peu la wii s'est montré tout à
l'heure finalement on n'invente rien le
premier roman oui enfin voilà mal c'est
ce qui est intéressant c'est un mérite
qui cherche la caméra semble pas cerné
voilà dix ans qu'il y avait deux
également d'intéressants avec ça c'est
qu'on pouvait mettre un disque ont été
une pile dédié piles et puis on écoutait
son disque ou tout simplement ça c'est
le bras c'est quand ça a marché sur le
lien je voulais les premiers sur
laquelle michel à te voilà alors ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant à savoir c'est
qu'en fin de compte il faut savoir que
le matériel
haut les idées en général par d'europe
et d'amérique dans tout ce qui est
matériel à londres par exemple là bas un
ampli qui à 30 ans d'âge 6 l'ampli
macintosh 275 c'est une pièce très très
rare les japonais sont les plus gros les
plus gros consommateurs en fin de compte
et toute l'électronique actuelle et les
amplificateurs actuelle et michel tous
que tout le monde connaît par à partir
de cette sonorité c'est la base ccc
l'objectif c'est d'essayer de restituer
sont là est il exact que leurs effectifs
en leçons des lampes est bien supérieur
aux 130 historisées alors départ d'avoir
du snobisme du moule du vieil ampli on
n'aura jamais retrouvé à laquelle
allanche justement alors à ce niveau là
les longues sur le papier par rapport à
un transistor la lampe est supposé être
moins bonne aujourd'hui les plus grandes
marques de matériel hi-fi l'ailé plus
ésotériques un peu comme comme cette
enceinte transparence et un médecin en
2001 cris nommé également je parle de
l'an 2000 un amplificateur on reprend
les techniques à l'amp et on recommence
à fabriquer d'allant parce que sur le
papier c'est moins bon mais à l'oreille
c'est beaucoup plus agréable
à tel point qu'il existe le meilleur
compact disc actuellement considéré dans
le monde est un compact disc à l'anc où
on utilise également des tubes donc
c'est cette technique qu'on utilisait
dans les années
c'est très bien vous avez eu harcèlement
et ses habitudes ont mis à jour moi je
m'en souviens parce meilleure chose qui
me frappe quand il ya des choses qui
sont très jumelles rigueur sur le papier
mais en quels sont les critères vaut
quelque chose avoue adorer ça s'adresse
en fait ont décidé de quelque chose qui
dépend des gens sur du papier je vous
l'expliqué simplement quand tu sais
quand on écoute une enceinte il ya une
bande passante c'est à dire qu'il ya
comme un comme un électrocardiogramme et
il ya également une réalité de l'ecoute
dans la mesure où le son c'est une
sensation on écoute une enceinte et on
regarde pas sa fiche technique et non au
niveau de la fiche technique un ampli à
transistor peut paraître de meilleure
qualité au niveau d'une écoute pur un
ampli alan dale et clermont son horizon
se démener radio pierre bouteiller
finalement l'âge d'or c'est les années
50 l'arrivée de la télé fin fin des
émissions non 60 aussi parce que quand
même ce sont les années 60 a correspondu
à toute une série d'éléments qui ont
enrichi la radio il ya eu d'abord la
transistors isation la mobilité de
l'écouté également du microsillon qui
explosent et marcel le sait bien le
microsillon 45 tours plus est en
d'historisation ça fait ça décuple et
l'écouté de la radio est également la
conjoncture politique
c'était les années de la décolonisation
c'était les années de gaulle c'était les
années de la fin de la quatrième du
passage à la cinquième donc à une écoute
de la radio à l'époque où la télévision
était encore pato de ne pouvait pas se
déplacer beaucoup et une écoute pour
l'information l'actualité en particulier
l'actualité postcoloniale et politique
qui a été énorme ce qui fait que ça a
fait monter l'audience des postes
surtout la lime d'époque l'europe n'a
rien quelle est l'erreur et de
l'animateur qui a vraiment marqué cette
année en vous y en a eu beaucoup
c'est pas des pages en noir annonce et
avant non non
moi je ne sais pas c'est une trêve et
c'était une très grande émission non
mais je crois que c'était excuse-moi
cité oui je ne suis pas rancunier j'ai
eu beau être foutu à la porte de
l'europe même si besoin est repris mais
loin mais c'est vrai qu'au point de vue
informations on n'a jamais
refais mieux en matière de radio que
l'époque d'europe numéro un dans les
années 60 c'est à dire avec sièges elle
gagner cette équipe là pour les
animateurs c'était bellemare
c'était cette journée verte et maurice
biraud c'est j'ai entendu dire et c'est
un débat maintenant à propos de la
roumanie ou entre où on a trouvé que les
images des télévisions pour vivante
qu'elle soit elle était un peu trop
hâtives
il paraît qu'on se replient de nouveau
dans l'information du moment sur la
radio il ya 80% de deux français qui
écoute au moins une fois la radio par
jour sont finalement il ya la télé
propos qu'aucun média nul autre la
télévision n'a pas tué le cinéma cinémas
pas tuer le théâtre cet élégant ne pas
tuer la radio ce n'est pas vrai et la
radio vivra toujours et la télévision
aussi d'ailleurs
[Musique]